so
so
[Music]
welcome to the press conference
following our informal meeting of the
council of the european union i give you
the floor
good afternoon to all of you obviously
i'd like to begin by thanking the french
president for his hospitality
in this magnificent setting which is
full of history and it's also made it
possible for us to work with the view to
the future particularly the future of
europe at a moment which is a difficult
one because we are
facing a war on the continent of europe
the versailles declaration has been
formally approved a few moments ago
and it will remain in the annals of the
european projects
and
there's a reason for this for some time
now we have understood
that it is essential to embark upon an
agenda of sovereignty of strategic
autonomy for the european union
[Music]
to be seen reflected in its ambition to
take into consideration the strengths
the advantages what brings the europeans
together but also take a look at the
fragilities that exist are going to try
to
correct and strengthen
this
meeting at versailles comes at a moment
when
just two weeks ago
russia embarked upon a war against
ukraine
and for two weeks now the european union
has demonstrated
how strong it is how solid it is
how united it is we've been able to come
together to decide in favor of
unprecedented sanctions which
we're there to support in every way
possible
financially in humanitarian terms
the men and women of ukraine
we have a european ambition
which is one of peace we've been
mobilizing equipment including military
equipment and some 500 million euros
additionally has been added to the
peace facility so we're there to support
ukraine
we've also been discussing the
application by ukraine as it was by
georgia and moldova
and we wanted to
make our point
clear to our ukrainian friends who of
course are full members of the european
family and we want to say to them that
we will stand by them and mobilize very
quickly in order to strengthen the links
that we have with the population of
ukraine and we will also be there to
support
their choices on their path
which is a european path
we have also had the opportunity to
discuss
the way in which europe can embark upon
the
agenda of sovereignty
let me quickly run through the three
pillars that we have today set out in
the declaration
we are looking to the future
in this way to
give an
impetus to the european project to make
it a committed and robust one first of
all we have the question of energy
this is not new today this challenge of
energy
we decided to embark upon
climate neutrality by 2050 and the idea
is to move towards greater independence
while facing the humanitarian challenges
and there are a number of points that we
want obviously to deal with
first of all is the question of prices
and the impact for families throughout
europe
and also for businesses
a question of dependence which is too
great that's what we're seeing today
particularly our dependence on russia
and we're pursuing that ambition we want
to release ourselves from that
dependency so that we can act
as best we can in line with our own
interests in line with our objectives
and obviously
for the next winter we need a particular
plan
now all of this
is
agreed on by the
council together with the commission
which is going to be following up on our
work here
and this is a very consistent agenda
that has been initiated secondly
the question of defense and security
defense europe we've been talking about
this for a long time some progress has
already been made but there's no denying
the fact that two weeks ago we woke up
in a different europe in a different
world
we can't deny the fact that the actions
taken over the last few days
in fact to consecrate
the
emergence of a european defense it has
formally been initiated through the
meeting today in versailles
and we have now an operational strategy
in which we will identify the
actions and investments that are going
to be necessary we've also identified
how it's going to be possible to roll
out a european industrial base
taking on board the different challenges
out of cyber security
that of space for instance just to cite
two examples
so there too
there's a timeline an agenda that has
been set
that is a mission for the commission
and
progress will be made further
third point that i'd like to mention
the importance of consolidating our
economic base
europa
is there to
work in the interest of peace security
and prosperity there's an economic
pillar in other words so it's up to us
it's up to our generation to take
decisions today that are going to make
that economic base far more robust far
more resilient
and
here i can refer to what we've done in
the area of health we've seen with
covert how important it is to coordinate
even
further there's also the ambition linked
to the semiconductors chips raw
materials critical materials
and of course the vital need to continue
to be committed to
innovation particularly technological
innovation
so just in a few words
that's what i can say about these very
significant decisions that i have that
have been taken today and there's a real
awareness shared by all of the leaders
of europe here in versailles
we're all aware of the importance of the
moment that we're living through and the
decisions that we're taking not just for
tomorrow and the next few months but for
coming generations
we must move towards peace prosperity
and security
these are the challenges we must pick up
so that we can see tangible results
more independence more sovereignty less
fragility and a greater ability to
determine our own fate for the european
union
we'll have the opportunity to come back
to the implementation of all of these
measures because it's going to be
european council in brussels in a few
two weeks time we'll be taking a look at
energy and other issues we also intend
before the june summit
to have an extraordinary summit
which means it will be able to take a
look again at security and defense so
once again i'd like to thank president
macron for having brought us here
today
in versailles at such a symbolic place
symbolic moment it's at the heart of
european history and yesterday and today
we
came together
to carry through this ambition for
europe thank you
merci charles mercier manuel
thank you charles thank you emmanuel
thank you for hosting us in such a
historic site
we're talking about the future of
ukraine and the future of the european
union and our democracies
and it is that history that is being
written as i speak
our destinies are linked ukraine is a
member of the european family putin's
aggression against ukraine is an
aggression an attack against all
the principles
that we hold dear it's an attack against
democracy
against
sovereignty of states
against the freedoms of a people to
choose its own destiny and shape its own
future
the way in which we respond today
to this
odious attack by russia against ukraine
will determine the future of ukraine and
also the future of our union and
going beyond that even the future of the
entire european continent so let us
remain faithful to the principles that
have been our guiding principles and our
common responses to date
its responsibility
unity
solidarity and determination
it made us face up to our
responsibilities
in the face of a new reality
first
our duty to continue ensuring reliable
secure and affordable supply of energy
to european consumers
in the midterm this means getting rid of
our dependency on russian gas
by diversification of supply
by massively investing in renewables
renewables are home grown they create
jobs here in europe
they are strategic investment in our
security and in our independence
and this is why the european commission
outlined
re-power eu this week
re-power eu is a plan
to diversify suppliers
and switch to renewables
by mid-may we will come up with a
proposal
to phase out our dependency on russian
gas oil and coal by 2027
backed by the necessary national and
european resources
but we also addressed energy price
spikes
by mid may the commission will present
options
to optimize the electricity market
design
so that it better supports the green
transition
but consumers and business need relief
now and therefore this week the
commission came forward with guidance on
price regulation
in these exceptional circumstances
and the possibility of a new temporary
crisis framework for state aid to
support struggling businesses
this is complemented by the option
giving to member states
to tax windfall profits
from energy groups
and finally by the end of this month
the commission will present options
to limit the contagion effect of the
rise of gas prices
to electricity prices
finally we need to be ready for the next
winter so we will set up a task force
that will design a refilling plan for
the next winter and coordinate the
operation
beyond this first step
the european union needs to define a
longer-term eu gas storage policy
and therefore the commission will table
a proposal
to fill up underground gas storages to
at least 90 percent
ninety percent of their capacity by the
first of october each year
so you see it's a whole big package and
this will be our insurance policy
against supply disruption
similarly the leaders also discussed
food prices and global food security
and here too the commission will come up
come forward with options
to address these important issues
putin's war has also fundamentally
altered europe's security environment
to defend europe we will need different
forces and different capabilities
significant additional defense
investments in europe will be needed
and i welcome that some leaders have
announced ambitious steps to increase
defence spending
more will follow
but we need to avoid fragmentation
thus we need a coordinated approach
because this only will ensure that we
maintain a military technological edge
in our european industrial base and that
interoperability is given between our
european armed forces
this will be the focus of our work in
the next weeks to come
i want to be very clear that we need to
closely coordinate also with nato nato
is the strongest military alliance in
the world
thus i welcome that the leaders have
tasked us
to prepare an analysis of the defense
investment gaps
and to make sure that we have a clear
plan how to deal with those gaps
in europe
by mid-may when the commission is
presenting the results of this
undertaking
the second principle i mentioned was
unity
it certainly guided us when we swiftly
imposed altogether
three successive waves of sanctions on
the kremlin
with an immediate hard-hitting effect
we will now come forward with the fourth
package of sanctions
these sanctions will further isolate
russia from the global economic system
increasing further the cost of putin's
invasion
to ukraine
and finally a word on solidarity
which so many europeans are showing
shining examples of in these days by
welcoming with open arms
more than two million people who have
now fled the war in ukraine
i want to thank all eu member states and
in particular
the countries in the front line that is
poland romania slovakia and hungary and
of course our partner moldova
because the people of ukraine need and
deserve all support
and so do the countries that welcome
them
the commission has set up a solidarity
platform
to coordinate
operational and financial support
and reception capacity
we're also using the flexibility of the
eu budget to the fullest
so that member states can finance
actions for refugees like for example
housing or schooling or medical care and
other topics
this could free this flexibility within
the commission could flee free
several billion euros over the coming
years for exactly these
purposes the ukrainian people are
showing immense courage
and the people that stand up so bravely
for european values
is clearly part of the european family
of nations
so while this terrible war rages on
we should already reflect carefully
about what comes next
the membership applications of ukraine
are expressions
of national sovereignty
of its will
and its right
to choose its own destiny
today we have opened the pathway towards
us for ukraine they are part of the
european family thank you
thank you madam president
mr president
the president of the republic
president president ladies and gentlemen
gentlemen
thank you for being with us here at the
end of the summit of versailles
president michelle and president
vanderline have
spoken clearly we're in the
gallery de bataille and if anyone
thought that
war in europe belonged to history
for the last two weeks we've seen that
the choice by
russia under president putin was to
bring war back to europe in the face of
this and the unheard of violence
of russia against ukraine and its
population is a tragic turning point for
our
history we're all aware of the fact that
it's a turning point as well for our
societies for our peoples and for our
european project
for the last two weeks our response
ladies and gentlemen this has just been
said we've responded through unity
rapidity and a spirit of responsibility
choices were made very quickly
all 27 with our institutions and
coordinated with all of our partners
in the context of nato and g7
diplomatic work has made it possible to
isolate russia israelia recently at the
general assembly of the united nations
for two weeks now ukrainian men and
women have been fighting courageously to
defend their freedom their democracy
their sovereignty and the integrity of
their land
europeans have a clear position
unanimous and firm condemnation of the
russian aggression
at all international levels and we've
drawn full consequences of this
interest with the
resolution that was adopted the general
assembly
support to ukraine together we've agreed
to deliver
hardware not just humanitarian material
but also weapons and we've proposed
today that the european
facility
be attitude to the tune of some 500
million which is going to allow us to go
further in this
line
countries that in the past were
traditionally neutral sweden for
instance have decided for the very first
time
that
in the for the first time in decades it
would take an active role in
the support to ukraine we also have
economic support humanitarian support
this will be contingent continued some 2
million refugees have been welcomed
madame van der leyen has referred to
this and i'd like to thank the
populations of the neighboring countries
poland hungary romania
and moldova as well
and obviously france will be playing its
role and i would hope that we will be
able to have the necessary mechanisms of
solidarity that can be used in this
overall approach as of the very outset
we also deployed
massive unheard of sanctions and this
was done very quickly
second
fourth six days of conflict they were
marked by european decisions
of these
unprecedented sanctions
we're willing to adopt other sanctions
and all options are on the table
the point of our discussion is to order
is to prepare ourselves for these
sanctions if they were
able to call a halt to the attack and
the aggression and could prepare us also
for
the consequences in the coming weeks and
months
our initial objective is of course a
rapid return to peace starting with the
ceasefire
followed by a rapid withdrawal of
russian troops and that is why keeping
up pressure on russia
and we're also maintaining a very
demanding dialogue
in particular in conjunction with the
german chancellor so the support to
solidarity for ukraine
is what kept us very busy particularly
yesterday
we support ukraine today and we will do
that for as long as the war lasts and we
will be there for the reconstruction of
this
destruction brought about by russia we
will be there to help it to stand up and
stay standing
the message that we've sent out to the
ukrainian population is that the path to
our europe is open to them their fight
for freedom and democracy for the values
that we all share has demonstrated that
ukraine is indeed a member of our
european family we also want the
applications
made by moldova and georgia as well
be examined in line with our treaty by
the european commission
so that
the acceptability can be determined
in line with the provisions of our
treaty
the versailles declaration
the agenda versailles that we've been
discussing today
is
linked to the fact that sovereignty in
europe
which
might have been thought of by some as a
slogan
or a sort of french fantasy
is seen by all today as being crucial
this sovereignty this
strategy of independence has been there
at the very start also of the pandemic
we've seen what had to be done it's
there when
we had to produce
and deliver vaccines for ourselves and
for other countries we've seen it when
we came out of the crisis uh the start
of the recovery when we saw what was
happening as we got these semiconductors
when we had delegated production to the
other parts of the world how difficult
it was to return to the manufacturing of
cars for instance and we're seeing
it in the context of this crisis where
we can see how
our food our energy our defense
are all issues of sovereignty we can
cooperate
we want to be open to the world but we
want to choose our partners and not
depend on any that is what we mean by
sovereignty it's not protectionism it's
not a question of closing the door it's
a question of having the possibility of
staying open without being dependent so
the versailles agenda has set out the
next few months work along those lines
as regards defense
we want to be able to define the
investments that we need and several of
us are already at the level of two
percent of gdp invested in defense
others have further efforts to make but
we're going to make coordinated efforts
we're going to identify our needs and
budgetary terms we're going to identify
capabilities that are required we'll
also identify our needs
when it comes to possible new conflicts
whether we're talking about shipping
maritime space
and also identify
what we need in order to develop the
european industrial
tissue
if we're going to import more in the way
of hardware from elsewhere then there's
not not much point pursuing this sort of
sovereignty we need to think in terms of
partnerships yes but we have to be able
to decide
to consolidate and to construct
a defense industry with fewer standards
but corresponding to an integrated
market
so the number of decisions that we've
already taken
about 10 days ago germany in turn
decided to make historic investments in
the count for the country
and denmark made an historic choice
deciding
to
ask the people if they want to come back
to the european security and defense
project you can see that everywhere
around the european continent historic
choices are being made and this is a
major turning point
we need to have the organization
so that we can build this joint ambition
in defense and this is what we have
asked the commission to do so that by
may
uh
when we will not have an extraordinary
meeting of the council before the nato
summit in june and the summit meeting in
june we will work up a plan which is
full for uh investment to get our
industries up to the right to the
capacity and capability level
and then
in the
we've got the question of
of climate strategy we've started
building our own independence getting
out of
fossil energy is a matter of becoming
independent and we know that moving away
from coal was a special point then we
moved to gas but that's gas that we have
imported and are still importing from
russia
the situation that we're in at the
moment and which we will have tomorrow
means we have to reassess this strategy
and be even more ambitious with our
climate plans
and for that
we will have a
a check on this by late march and see
how we can provide the support for our
populations for price and we're going to
work on this at the commission with
concrete
objectives for prices and for uh and for
refining so that we can guarantee their
mechanisms
which means that we're not subjected to
the contingencies of the market or
speculation of the market in
particular in crisis situations many of
you have already
taken steps to protect
our citizens and companies and we need
to have european choices and in the two
weeks to come we will
do our best to say that we can stand up
to the price shock which comes from the
geopolitical con context
prices were going up before the war and
they're continuing to increase because
of the war
then of course we have the sanctions
which are coming in and we must prepare
ourselves so that we are not so
sensitive to the dependency on
russia and this is what we've
scheduled for may for the commission as
the two presidents have pointed out we
have the plan to step out of the
dependency on fossil fuels from russia
so that we can get out by 2027 so that
we are no longer dependent on uh russian
gas oil and coal that's by 2027 this
means there has to be new investment new
facilities
so that we can
support our choices for renewables and
for nuclear energy you can see that much
and me will be very busy
for energy subjects
and there are other issues that we will
have to work together on
to ensure that we are independent and
sovereign there's the food strategy
and whether we're talking about wheat or
maize or grain crops in general we know
that ukraine and russia are two huge
markets
and europe has already been upset by the
war on the on the fruit supply market
and this will be even more so in it in
12 to 18 months
with the impact on ukraine and crops
there and there will be a major
disturbance to food supplies in
in foodborne feed supplies so we have to
strike a new balance and look at food
production so that we can have
autonomy for our food production and for
protein production and we must reassess
the strategy for africa because the
number of african countries are going to
be hit by famines in the next 12 to 18
months
because of this war
there's the sovereignty for other
commodities
and raw materials for rare materials
and i've mentioned the question of
semiconductors their health can i won't
go through the whole list but we have
this agenda we will be going through
this in the months to come with very
concrete proposals for investments which
will make it possible for to have more
sovereign and more independent europe
we will be
encouraging
private investments so this is the idea
with
the tax on energy
and we're going to have the union of
capitals and we're going to look at the
single market in different sectors
and we have to have the appropriate
monetary possible
we
we're not
going back in
to normal now it's quite clear and the
european uh essential the central
european bank will be following its work
and we'll be doing this very clearly in
the current geopath geopolitical context
and will have national investment
policies to protect us from the impact
of the war to fund our solidarity to
fund our resistance to the impact of the
war and to defend our sovereignty but
the next point is that we
need
to have
means of
funding these major strategies funding
from europe and
these are the things i mentioned and
this is why we need to have joint
funding we need to coordinate our
investments
and we should do it in a european
context so that we don't see the
financial markets being broken up and
and different forms of sovereign debt
and this is what we've been working on
as our strategy and we'll be working on
it for the months to come and here we
will have to be
acting together acting swiftly and with
a spirit of responsibility
the ukrainians have given
us an example which is quite unique the
example of courage
we are not waging war
europe is not waging war on russia but
we're supporting
ukraine and we're sanctioning russia
but we must have the courage to make
historic decisions and
to see that the defense of democracy and
our values has a cost the choice of
independence has a cost and sometimes we
have to go back on some of the dogmas
that we'd been following for years the
different habits and the ways of
organizing things which we had and i can
tell you that the discussions we had
yesterday and today
have
realized this awareness
and we can see there's a real ambition
here from the europeans here in
versailles advance in that direction and
i would like to conclude on that
i we started the work yesterday by
extending thanks to some of the
colleagues i would like to say this to
the president of the commission because
here in versailles it's a very historic
site which the french of course love
above all and which we're very proud of
and we see it it's known around the
world but it's a site which is also the
site of diplomatic defeats
it's the site where we lost peace at the
at
the end of the world war
and
we
we were
we were there
it with an ambition to humiliate and
divide europa with with the treaty of
vexa
and despite
the difficulties we've had here today
with the emotions and
uh
different attitudes we did have a
unanimous
agreement on the fact that the only way
of protecting our continent was through
unity through courage and unity that's
the most important thing thank you
thank you chair
i would like to inform you
that we've just published our versa
declaration in the 24 languages of the
european
the versailles declaration and we're
going to take a few questions in the
room
um
okay
from radio france
now
you had a two-day summit and
you've been talking about european more
powerful face of moscow you're talking
about an agenda you've talked about 2027
you've talked about other possible
sanctions but we've seen
what's happened in the field with kiev
surrounded and the maternity hospital
bombed and we can see that sanctions are
not enough and the feeling is that
you don't really have any other tools or
unanimous agreement for swift strong
action
and
something which could
make persian back down now are you in a
state where you're just impotent now now
let's be clear there is war there but we
are not
at war what you've stated is true but
the political reality the sovereign
choice is that one as i said we are not
at war you're quite right to see that we
don't have a response in a theater of
war which was triggered by russian
aggression because we are not there in
the theater of war
have we excluded additional sanctions
certainly not the g7 the statement which
will be issued in a few hours will uh
will
confirm additional sanctions and then
depending on what happens
in
the country in ukraine we are not
excluding other
possibilities now if things continue in
the
military way that you've just described
we may take
further sanctions including massive
sanctions but at this point in time
europeans are intervening in three
different ways
there are sanctions against russia
and we'll take other sanctions there
and if the circumstances required we
will take follow those sanctions to the
very end then there's support for
ukraine which we will continue to do
and then there's diplomatic action to
isolate russia at the united nations and
to convince president putin to come back
to the negotiation table in since in
true sincerity with the president of
ukraine so as to find an agreement
this is the framework of our actions
and of course we if we speak out against
and condemn entirely what happens what
has happened in kharkiv and in maripo
which is
totally unacceptable
but
for the moment
the europeans we as europeans we are not
at war in ukraine indeed it is atrocious
it is atrocious this bombardment of the
maternity
hospital for example
and i think there needs to be
investigations about the question of war
crimes therefore this has to be
reflected and recorded
uh soberly
but i would also support the fact i mean
we are at day 15 of this horrible war
and as the president said on we were
well prepared on day two day four and
day six
we had each
time a massive package of sanctions
today a week later
you see that the ruble is in free fall
it has lost more than 50 percent
compared to the euro
you see that they are skyrocketing
interest rates in russia
you see a soaring
inflation
the rating agencies do rate
the russian
bonds as
junk by now and recession is hitting the
country this within 15 days this shows
the severity and the impact of our
sanctions
and therefore the fourth package will
come
and as the president said we have our
way to answer to the atrocious
aggression that putin is showing
and we will be determined and forceful
in the answer
thank you madam president
the next question is for i got from bfm
tv
the president sir
now for the french president the 27 have
refused to have a
swift accession of
ukraine to the european union and
the ukrainian president has asked you to
do more and has asked for political
decisions to be in line with the
feelings of the people i'd like to know
how you cope with the uh the criticism
that comes almost on a daily basis from
kiev and do you think eu membership for
ukraine is a is a dream or is it is it
really achievable and i have another
question that i wanted to ask in
concrete terms for sanctions
have you decided to have two third
reduction of
russian gas imports by the end of the
year which has been suggested by the
president of the commission and uh
could they there be something to solve
between more sanctions and restricting
purchases in europe and you don't you
think there might be social response to
this and you might end up with a
visually shown response
now to answer your second question by
developing mechanisms we've shown that
we could
adopt sanctions and protect ourselves
from the consequences have joint
protection for consumers and companies
but of course let's be clear obviously
the world market the global market for
raw materials and
it
was already going up in price before the
war that's for gas oil and other
commodities or industrial components
there was already an increase in prices
so you need to make a distinction there
and the governments are not
here to cope with all inflation
france for example has coped with a lot
of
inflation and that's quite
exceptional
take the example of chaos
with gas
we didn't have a major impact from the
crisis and the sanctions and where the
market went up by 40 percent it only
went up four percent for consumers
because we had a shield
in place now we get work on other
european mechanisms too so what i'm
seeing is that we think and we know that
we have the wherewithal to impose
sanctions
and to cope with counter sanctions and
to protect our economies because we have
the strength at a national level and at
a european level
as for your other question
the recipe
i think we must show great respect and
solidarity for the people of ukraine and
the leaders of ukraine
and i can understand the emotional
response and the expectations that are
there
yesterday the european council conveyed
a very strong and clear message
that was the message about
the
fate of ukraine in europe and the path
to its
destiny there now could we have
exceptional measures with the country
which is at war without uh respecting
the criteria the answer is no
could we say that we would then abandon
neighboring moldova which is so fragile
with transnistria and the presence of
external forces and the dependency on
russian gas and refugees turning up
obviously the answer is no
if
we were there
in the war could we forget that the the
way the other western balkan states have
been
trying to join the union and have been
doing it for so long and they're in a
fragile state and they're impacted by
the geopolitical situation too so
obviously we can't do that so you can
see yesterday we sent out a very clear
message a political message and we're
expressing a heartfelt wish to uk saying
our path is with you and our family is
your family but in the months
to come
we will have to have an in-depth
reassessment of what our europe is
and
i think i can tell you that
with the geopolitical situation and the
tragic return of war and the revisionism
in history and the ambitions for power
and hegemony mean we have to think about
how we want to organize a larger europe
which is
not necessarily europe with the same
public policies that we have that we
have in in the france and other
countries in the european union but we
will have to include other countries who
otherwise would be destabilized by
political islamism by the whims of
russia or by
invasion from china and moving in at our
at our gateways and this means we will
have to look again at the way we govern
ourselves the way we organize ourselves
and this is why we have decided to have
a conference on the future of europe
this is a geopolitical awareness which
is much greater given this context and
this means we will have to get our ideas
coming together by summer this year and
we will have to find new forms for our
europe i'm convinced of that
indeed presidency has
with his application
set a process in motion
and um
i just wanted to remind that
from the day of the application
to today um it was just
a very short time that the council
tasked the commission to form an opinion
on this application normally this takes
years
so it shows that there is a completely
different process going on the process
itself is important as the president
said there is their conditions to be
part of the european union that have to
be met but we are also aware of the fact
that having a free and democratic
ukraine after the war will also mean
that a lot of rebuilding the country
will be done with strong support from
the european union too so i want to
emphasize that
there is an enormous speed in the
process over the last days really to
show that ukraine is indeed part of our
european family on your second question
on
the two third reduction
potential reduction of russian gas
within a year
indeed this is doable
it's not a ban it is a reduction by
going on one hand in the diversification
of the supply so making sure that we
have a lot more lng coming to the
european union and that pays off that
over the last weeks we've been working
hard and have been calling all our
friends around the world and we have
many friends around the world that we
need higher supplies of lng gas thanks
god we've done our homework and we have
the lng terminals there have been
investments massive investments in the
pipeline network throughout the european
union so with the lng terminals and an
increased lng supply we're able
to replace quite a part
of the russian gas an example is the
january we never had so many lng vessels
and so high amounts of lng
supply to the european union as in the
month of january because we just
actively asked the other suppliers in
the world then of course
it needs to be accompanied by heavy
investment in renewables but also
biomethane for example or increase in
hydrogen this will rise over the years
this is the beginning only it's one of
the most interesting projects to invest
in the hydrogen because whatever we do
now with the lng gas and the pipelines
can one day be used as infrastructure
for hydrogen so it's a perfect
transition into the hydrogen that will
be one of the energy sources of the
future and then of course
you can see in the communication that
um the commission put on the table this
tuesday
a detailed table with the different
sectors where we can also reduce the
energy energy consumption thus
reduce our dependency on russian gas
last but not least it's not going to be
easy it's going to be hard
and
as i've already said
it needs the support by everybody
everyone can do something for example by
reducing the energy consumption we have
overall
the individual contribution by 450
million europeans makes a big chunk if
you look at that and the combination of
diversification more renewables and
smart use of energy
would make it possible
let me also say that ukrainians today
are
fighting with a courage that really
impresses us all they're fighting for
their land they're fighting for their
sovereignty they're fighting for their
children
and for their future and they're
fighting so they can belong to the free
world fundamentally
they are fighting for our values as
europeans
around the table yesterday there was a
total agreement among all of the leaders
that there is a real need a vital need
for us as european union to show that we
have courage as well
that means an ability to act
to
without
waiting without hesitating committing
and bringing in as much as we can in all
sectors possible in all circumstances
the process well you've already had an
answer on that the process will continue
and the commission will issue
an opinion
and we will in the meantime be
continuing the discussion at the level
of the european council on this issue
but i really want to say to you that my
firm conviction is that this
huge respect felt for the way in which
the ukrainians
have a lesson for us all to learn from
on freedoms and we have to be committed
to show that we
can live up to their hopes and
aspirations
from bloomberg you're next john
hello if i could ask a question in
english please of of all the
participants um actually two questions
the first one is on refugees the british
government has announced measures to
relax
um entry into the uk for ukrainian
nationals with passports i wanted to ask
you if this is enough for easing their
entry in the country and if you believe
that the uk is now
doing its fair share of the burden and
the other question on spending on
defense and um
and energy um
what was the the uh what were the
reflections
on the idea of common debt was there a
consensus
or is there division on this thank you
on the first point let me say that i
welcome the change in position of the uk
which goes to show that there was a
problem notwithstanding what might have
been said at the time and i don't think
anyone could have understood that after
so many strong statements that we
share that the uk government had
continued to
implement the existing rules which means
not welcoming the ukrainian refugees who
wanted to come to the uk saying that
they have to travel hundreds of
kilometers in order to apply for a visa
so it's
a glimmer of pragmatism and it's
starting to
[Music]
align itself with some of the
decorations and statements which is a
step in the right direction and it seems
to be
working well there
it's going in the right direction
although much remains to be done and i'd
like to thank the uk government and i
think that the french home office
minister letter was probably a useful
one and i would hope that the
ukrainian men and women
who have lived through horrors who have
crossed europe
to
reach their families on uk territory
will be
better treated
obviously we'll be doing what we can and
we're trying to cut back on the red tape
so that they can
reach more dignified
living conditions
so i'd like to thank the uk government
for this first step and it's over the
coming days that we'll be able to see
whether it's enough or whether more
effective measures are going to be
required
we have also said that we are
willing to
house in lille or other cities a place
for the administrative procedures to be
run through and then on the question of
the common debt joint debt
i think that the right strategy as we've
seen during the pandemic
is to agree on objectives and when we do
that when you reach agreement on
objectives then the instruments just
follow if we start by working on the
instruments given that we have divisions
and disagreements generally things don't
move forward and we waste time
so
aaron
well first of all we've seen this
unanimity today
unanimity to as we got the need to
invest
all sorts of types of sovereignty
digital food
energy and so on all of that is covered
and then we give a mandate to the
commission to do the work to say how
much
is to be needed that has to be assessed
and through that we can see what can be
covered by the private sector won't be
covered by the public sector and
depending on all of that and and how
quickly it's done we'll have a
discussion as regards the actual
resources and the mechanisms
in any case
it's certainly not a past debt
but we can be talking about activating
mechanisms that already been used for
example in the situation of the pandemic
but this question of the instruments the
instruments are only there as a means to
the end there's unanimity as regards the
strategic objective and now the march
and may summits will make it possible
for us to clarify our operational
objectives
which will make it possible for us to
identify the tools the instruments will
get us there
that's how we're going to go through
this
what your first question is concerned
indeed we welcome this improvement for
the ukrainian refugees this is a good
step in the absolute right direction
as you know in the european union
already a week ago
we have activated the so-called
temporary protection directive for the
very first time in the history of the
european union
this gives gives all ukrainian
immediately residency rights and by that
of course access to the labor market
immediately access to schools to medical
care to otherwise support
so that these poor innocent people
immediately find a home here and can get
on
to try to
accommodate in the european union what
the second question is concerned
indeed i want to underline that it has
proven right
that we first define the priorities and
the necessities to invest in them
and i want to recall that from the
beginning of our mandate we have defined
three priorities it's the european green
deal
it is digitalization
and it is resilience
and throughout the pandemic as well as
now throughout this
times of war that russia is unleashing
they have proven to be the right
priorities the european green deal is
absolutely necessary if we want to get
independent of fossil fuels mainly by
russia
supplied by russia the digitalization is
of utmost importance to modernize our
economy which proves now
to be the leverage against russia's war
machine
and resilience of course defense is a
subtitle of resilience
and
it is important as the president said
that we look at all different tools we
can then activate to make it possible
that we advance in our priorities this
is on the one hand the european level
and there is as well the european budget
as for example next generation eu it is
the national level but we should also
not forget the private level
and a good example how to activate all
three levels
and
make the projects advance
is now for example our
chips act
concerning the semiconductors
here we push forward a crucial topic
that goes for the digitalization as well
as our resilience that is our
independence
with the european investment and
national investment and triggering
private investment
thank you angela mauro
from huffington post you have the last
question
okay thanks baron
two quick questions uh what do you reply
to mr zelinski who is saying he's
disappointed from the declaration of
versailles he asked europe to do more
and he says it's not enough and then i
wanted to know when you say you're
preparing another package of sanctions
and you're ready to everything else that
is on the table uh
is it on the table an embargo petroleum
gas from russia is on the table or the
exclusion of us burbank and gazpro
gazprom bank
from swift is on the table as well
thanks
as regards your first question
let me say once again that with a great
deal of respect and consideration for
president zielinski and his citizens who
are fighting
the political message that the european
union sent from versailles yesterday is
a clear message
we played the ukrainian national anthem
here we sent a very clear political
message
now it's
not a legal process for the reasons that
i've already cited in answer to one of
your colleagues questions and also
president michelle and president
frondeline have made the point as well
now i fully understand that when
involved in battle so courageously as
the ukrainians are at the same time as
last week when there was a request for a
no-fly zone
obviously much more is wanted
but we are not
parties to the conflict let me say that
we are determined to do everything
useful to bring about an end to the
conflict and peace can come back to
ukraine
the european
path is a clear one for ukraine we've
made that point very clearly secondly
our desire to continue to support
ukraine and the ukrainians is clear and
we've demonstrated it we've taken
decision on this
thirdly we're willing to sanction
sanction beyond what has already been
done
so
nothing from what you've mentioned is
uh
off the table
i
preserve the strategic ambiguity because
i think it's good i think it's
beneficial to us
additional decisions will be taken
following the g7 they will be limited
but if
russia not with something what it says
notwithstanding president putin saying i
believe in discussions negotiations
things are moving forward i see that
things are changing
in a few hours time we'll be talking to
president putin again together with
chancellor schultz and if despite that
he steps up the bombing he's
puts kiev kiev under siege
then we know
that further massive sanctions will have
to be taken by us
the message i want to put across to you
here is that in that case
nothing is off the table nothing is
taboo we will do
whatever we deem to be
effective
and useful
to halt russia
in its aggression
let me also say that as regards the
different packages of sanctions each
time around we've been able to bring
things together very quickly whenever
necessary and to act when necessary and
yesterday evening's a meeting
demonstrated this again the ability to
work as europeans to work with our
partners to prepare things together and
we can see the impact of these sanctions
they're having a real effect and we're
going to continue
to assess the situation
so that we can take the right decisions
at the right time in order to bring
about a change in the kremlin's position
and bring it to a state of mind that'll
make it possible we hope for there to be
a ceasefire and a
cessation of facilities as quickly as
possible
thank you very much
thank you president thank you ladies and
gentlemen